a major real-estate proposal by
President Trump CBS News has learned
that mr. Trump wants to buy Greenland
the Danish legislators have called the
idea grotesque and as Seth Doane has
learned not everyone in the world's
largest island is warming up to the idea
Greenland's strategic location stunning
landscape and natural resources are
undoubtedly appealing but Denmark says
this territory is not for sale maybe
it's crazy you thought the president was
crazy yeah I think so this would not be
the first time the US has tried to buy
this place the State Department made an
inquiry back in 1867 and then after
World War two President Harry Truman
offered a hundred million dollars to buy
Greenland but both attempts failed but
in 1917 Denmark did sell the Danish West
Indies to the United States today
they're known as the US Virgin Islands
United States has had an airbase deep in
the Arctic up in northern Greenland
since 1943 we took a helicopter out to a
remote glacier to meet scientists
studying the ice melt what would you
make of that suggestion of the u.s.
trying to buy Greenland I think you
should talk to Denmark President Trump
is traveling to Denmark in September and
a White House official with knowledge of
the trip says the White House expects
the issue of Greenland to come up and
staffers are preparing for it folks here
will most certainly be watching - for
CBS this morning Saturday Seth Doane
cool o-silk Greenland I've got a Thule
Air Base there US hugely strategically
important you can understand why someone
would want to buy it you could also
understand why they wouldn't want to
sell it not everything has a price right
right my point exactly
this is why we get a little